tom cruise only took the role so he
could do what
how much is he actually flying in the
films and why did he flip on his
decision to never make a top gun sequel
here's everything you never knew about
top guns maverick
it's nearly impossible to imagine
maverick being played by anyone other
than tom cruise but as it turns out
another actor was actually offered the
part before cruz came on board the part
was initially offered to actor matthew
modine who turned down the role because
he didn't agree with the film's politics
he went on to star in stanley kubrick's
full metal jacket instead a role that
remains one of his most memorable
speaking with salon in 2020 modine has
said he does not regret turning down the
rolling top gun all those years ago
despite what it did for cruz's career he
explained
cruz said that he felt that top gun was
a movie about individualism and personal
strength i just thought the movie was
jingoistic
while full metal jacket is also about
the armed forces modine maintains that
it does not endorse the actions of the
military but rather indicts the
regressive violent values that these
institutions espouse
for his part cruz told playboy that top
gun was never meant to represent the
reality of the us military and was
created for purely entertainment
purposes
when it came down to casting top gun
director tony scott relied on someone he
could trust a member of his own family
prior to top gun tom cruise was working
on a film called legend which was
directed by tony's brother ridley scott
in an interview for the 30th anniversary
release of the film cruz recalled that
he was first offered the role in the
film in 1983 but he was in the middle of
filming legend at this time i was off in
london working with ridley scott who had
just done blade runner though legend
wasn't received very well by critics
cruz maintains that it was a hugely
important learning experience for him
and taught him a lot about the work that
goes into making a film once he was done
with legend though ridley scott urged
cruz to look at the top gun role
at the end of 1984 ridley said you know
you gotta meet my brother and he's gonna
direct this film top gun you know it's
aligned with things that i love movies
and aviation
by this point cruz was in a position to
accept the role of maverick and the rest
is history
so you're the one
[Music]
spam
tom cruise and top gun producer jerry
bruckheimer actually have pretty
different stories about how cruz came to
be cast as maverick
in an interview with variety rockheimer
said that it took considerable effort to
get cruz to sign onto the film he
explained
we wanted tom after we saw risky
business and he kind of hemmed and hawed
so we arranged for him to fly with the
blue angels at the naval air facility in
el centro california
the pilots decided to give him the ride
of his life in order to scare him to
death but as bruckheimer tells it this
is actually what convinced cruz to do
the movie but tom cruise has said this
wasn't actually how it went down and i
said listen here's a deal i'm gonna make
this movie
but don't tell anyone that yet
he claimed that the reason he didn't
reveal his excitement about the project
at first was that he wanted the
opportunity to fly with the blue angels
something bruckheimer was happy to
provide for him while crews admitted
that he spent much of his first flight
with the blue angels vomiting all over
the cockpit he maintains that it was
well worth it in the end it's a
well-known fact that tom cruise takes
his work as an action star very
seriously
taking the time to really prepare for
his roles and often doing his own stunts
in the case of top gun cruz did what one
would imagine he would do to prepare for
the role he shadowed real-life pilots
according to time top gun is the
nickname of a real military school
called the navy fighter weapons school
that was founded in 1969 at the height
of the vietnam war as part of his
training for the role crews shadowed
pilots at the school
while there crews reported that an
instructor told him
there are only four jobs in the world
worth having an actor a rock star a jet
fighter pilot and president
kelly mcgillis who played maverick's
love interest charlie shadowed the woman
her character was based on christine fox
a woman who worked for the center for
naval analyses in 2013 fox was named
acting deputy defense secretary by
president barack obama making her the
highest ranking woman to ever serve in
the department of defense
what does top gun have in common with
films like the bling ring and hustlers
you ask well all of these films were
inspired by magazine articles
the magazine article in question was
titled top guns and it was published by
california magazine in 1983. the piece
covers the high octane world of fighter
pilots
one element of the film that was clearly
inspired by the article is the nicknames
of the pilots their names like maverick
and iceman were created for the film the
article explained that pilots were often
called things like yogi gringo gator and
possum
while there's not a specific pilot
mentioned in the article that directly
inspired maverick the article goes into
the intensity of the job and how many
pilots lived for the glorious and
terrifying thrill of flying tomcats
these days because top gun has made the
real school so famous students at the
navy fighter weapons school are actually
fined five dollars every time they
reference the film while at the academy
i feel the need
first get out
get out
there's one every year i will not
tolerate clowning
tom cruz isn't the tallest guy out there
he's reportedly around five foot seven
which means his female co-stars are
sometimes significantly taller than he
is
this happened to be the case in top gun
where crews starred opposite kelly
mcgillis who stands at around five feet
ten inches tall speaking with the
oklahoman mcgillis recalled well first
off tom and director tony scott and i
really weren't bothered by the height
difference but apparently paramount was
as such measures needed to be taken for
the scenes they shared to make them
closer in height i acted in my bare feet
most of the time i slouched a lot my
posture in that movie is appalling
mcgillis noted that while she had a
great time making the film looking back
she can now see that she was trying to
shrink herself more and more as the film
went on nonetheless the experience was
something mcgillis is used to as she
riley recalled there have been a lot of
men that i've worked with that i don't
wear shoes with
unsurprisingly given that it's a
blockbuster sequel everything in top gun
maverick is bigger and better than it
was in the original there are bigger
faster jets more realistic action
sequences and even drones in the new
film
while all of these advancements were
necessary for updating the film and
aligning it with contemporary technology
it also meant that cruz couldn't quite
do everything himself though cruz is an
experienced pilot himself jerry
bruckheimer admitted that the navy
denied cruz's request to pilot the f-18
super hornet jet that maverick flies in
the film
despite this cruz took it upon himself
to pilot every other aircraft he could
bruckheimer told empire the navy
wouldn't let him fly an f-18 but he
flies a p-51 in the movie and he flies
helicopters he can do just about
anything in an airplane
in order to get around the fact that
cruz couldn't pilot the f-18 himself
producers engineered some pretty
ingenious camera setups
cruz was adamant that the film not rely
on cgi so instead imax cameras were
actually installed inside f-18s while
navy pilots did the actual flying i told
everyone if you're gonna take this role
part of it is being in that f-18 i don't
know how to do it any other way
in the first couple of decades of his
career tom cruise was adamant that he
didn't want to make sequels for any of
his films
this all changed when he starred in the
first mission impossible film which
spawned multiple sequels
according to cinema blend he eventually
decided that sequels could be a fun
challenge for the cast and crew
for many years cruz was also similarly
disinterested in making a sequel to top
gun in fact in 1990 cruz spoke to
playboy magazine about the possibility
of a sequel saying
some people felt that top gun was a
right-wing film to promote the navy and
a lot of kids loved it but top gun was
just an amusement park ride a fun film
with a pg-13 rating that was not
supposed to be reality
that's why i didn't go on and make top
gun two and three and four and five that
would have been irresponsible this was
32 years ago now so we don't blame cruz
for changing his mind on the subject
since then just want to manage the
expectations
despite cruz's hesitance to sign on for
a sequel to top gun for many years
director joseph kaczynski was eventually
able to convince him
part of kozinski's pitch had to do with
the journey that maverick would go on in
the film and the first step in getting
the film made was to pitch the idea to
cruise himself
as kozinski told deadline i started the
discussion with what i thought should be
the emotional core of the film the
severed relationship between maverick
and goose's son set against a dangerous
combat mission that would take them both
deep into enemy territory
as soon as i said that i could see the
wheels in tom's head starting to turn my
dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
kaczynski went on to say that the latter
half of his pitch revolved around what
maverick would be doing in the navy at
the time the film is set
kaczynski also told crews that they were
thinking of rigging cameras inside the
cockpits of the jets
interestingly enough an attempt at that
exact same filming approach had been
made in the original top gun producer
jerry bruckheimer explained to empire
what's different about this movie is
that in top gun we put the actors in the
f-14s and we couldn't use one frame of
it except some stuff on tom because they
all threw up so everything was done on a
gimbal but in this movie tom wanted to
make sure the actors could actually be
in the f-18s
according to kaczynski cruz was
immediately on board following the
conversation even going so far as to
call up the head of the studio
immediately after he heard kozinski's
pitch
when the trailer for top gun maverick
was released some fans were skeptical as
to why maverick would still be a captain
in the navy after more than 30 years of
service
this issue is actually brought up in the
film yet here you are
captain
while this does address the elephant in
the room it doesn't actually answer the
question of why maverick is still a
captain this question became so
controversial that the navy felt
compelled to provide answers the navy
personnel command spoke with usni news
to speculate about how this turn of
events could have happened it turns out
it is possible but it's unlikely
one explanation would be if maverick had
left active duty sometime after the
events of the first top gun film and
spent several years in the navy reserves
another scenario would be if maverick
was retired but retained in service
this situation is unlikely as most
people do not serve past their mandatory
retirement but the navy says it is
possible check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you